yo what's up everybody just prestige
your man luigi here with another
Borderlands the pre-sequel video and
today we're gonna be looking at the Mork
which is a new legendary shield released
at the same time of the Clapp tastic
voyage DLC and in the club tastic voyage
ELC in one of the new areas there is a
spot that you can always get a Mork one
time so you can get a one time and it's
guaranteed but you can only get it one
time so yeah and I do believe that you
can get the shield than any normal loot
drop ways of the killing enemies however
that would take a very long time since
there's no specific boss to drop this
shield that is known yet so I'm gonna
show you the good way to get it now as
you can see this is a engine shield and
it's elemental resistance it matches the
elements the elements of the last
element damage received so if you get
shot by some crow suit you would now
have a 67% corrosive resistance shield
and then a fire so on and so forth this
is actually in reference to a TV show
starring Robin Williams in like the late
70s early 80s and called Mork & Mindy
and this shield actually does talk to
you and they have a voice actor that's
really close to Robin Williams it's just
kind of weird since he died he died like
a few months ago I think it was and the
rent tax I'm I have to look on my screen
really close because it's small my
screen but hold up the red text says a
face in the crowd I fit right in see
that might be in reference to something
in the show um but yeah oh now I have no
idea what it means so yeah so we're
gonna hop into the video I'm gonna show
you where it is it is in the as I said
in the classic voyage ELC so you're
gonna have to head on in there and you
have to do part of it I'm gonna have to
do enough of the deal see that you get
to where you're gonna need to be so
you're gonna want to head to the
motherless board and you're gonna see on
the map I kinda try and find it it's
right around you see where that the
yellow exclamation point for mission is
it's right around there and you can
follow my path to it if that isn't good
enough
instructions for you which I would not
be surprised if it isn't so you're just
gonna run through run through the map
like normal is gonna be like a few
pockets of enemies they're not not too
hard for me at least I am Nisha who's
completely overpowered but it's it's not
it's pretty basic enemies you can see
that that exclamation point that's where
we're going as I show a little more
clearly then and so you're gonna you're
gonna find the shield in a chest and I
believe that this shield never never
spawns again in that chest but you can
always it always spawns the first time
you look in that dress I don't know if
the chest spawns afterwards since the
chest has some has some like I get a
head like greens and blues in it when I
went so you're gonna ride the blue
circuit and it right there as you saw is
where it's gonna be a little different
than normal travel you have to ground
pound out of that and then follow these
boosters we're gonna be going to that
platform thing on the left at the um let
my sent that the orange to goes through
they're pretty they're pretty alright
jumps out yeah there's one more jump at
here it makes it pretty easy this is
gonna send you to the top make sure you
don't go into the orange stuff there's a
canister of weapons if you wanna check
that out so head over here and just drop
down and make sure you don't die and
there's the chest and you're gonna see
the Mork is gonna be in the left the
left
yeah the therapeutic more that's what I
got so I had do not have any gameplay of
me fighting with it however I did I did
fight a little bit with it and it
against um some kind of basic enemies
but it did pretty well so I think it's
alright Shield has a pretty quick
recharge rate however it's not a huge
capacity and you can see when someone
ever gets depleted you take it off or
you put it on it will stalk like and
every time I've put it on it said good
evening claptrap I think it is however
good evening claptrap yeah um but I do
believe that it changes has it has a lot
of stuff to say when you drop it or it
gets depleted
so yeah that's basically the video guys
hope you've enjoyed this and leave a
like if you have and I'll see you later